hello everyone and welcome to gamespot
of Thrones I'm Lucy I'm tomorrow and man
it's episode 9 it's going on it finally
it's the big one and honestly I've had
middling feelings about this season so
far but my goodness that's not delivered
definitely lady kept delivered they
never go short on the episode nines and
I think this is possibly my favorite one
so far but we're gonna go in-depth on me
yep so if you haven't seen the episode
definitely turn away now but if you have
seen come revel in it with us
so this episode is called battle of the
bastards and I thought that the whole
thing would be taking place on that
battlefield just outside of Winterfell
but no it did take us to marine for a
little bit yep so in marine we picked up
pretty much exactly where we left off
last week the Masters are laying siege
to the city and we've got Tyrion kind of
putting his tails between his very tiny
legs and being like yeah I screwed up
but you know I also did this and this no
but no sex although it's not all bad but
the nurses like you screwed up I left
you in charge and you messed up but then
she starts talking about her plan and
how she's going to retaliate and it
turns out to be quite a lot like her
plan to her father's plan which was
basically kill everything and Tyrians
like oh god this is sorry so she kind of
reminds her of mad mad Kings kind of
planning what happened and then for some
reason recounts the kind of detail that
Jamie told him about the the wild fire
underneath King's Landing I don't think
I think that's a deliberate drop yeah so
but it's it's like almost too like
obvious that it's a drop so he says he
killed Jamie killed the Mad King because
there was for you know world fell
underneath King's Landing and also
there's some interceptor balogh anyways
well know what's happening there next
week so yeah so that happens and then we
skip ahead a bit and we get the
confrontation between the Masters and
team Daenerys and it's a bit of like
back and forth jabbing and it's awesome
yeah it's going like this yeah the guy
looks like Neil druckmann with this move
his hand a vagina Oh the last of us yeah
but then they're kind of like doing the
jabbing and the Masters are under the
impression that they've got the upper
hand and then as one of them's like
listen guys you need to give up in the
distance you can see a very faint
silhouette of a dragon getting bigger
and bigger approaching and you're like
okay this is how it's going down and
then kind of drug on swoops behind and
lands in front and she's like my rule is
just beginning see you later jumps on
the dragon and gets out of there I do
wonder how she trained drogue on to
arrive at that particular moment just
like you have to wait until I say the
very awesome badass line then that's
when you learned
let's practice this yeah and then shake
a bit so you look real dragony and rural
threatening and then she gets on and you
can see like the masters are like good
we screwed up oh this is bad news so
like then it cuts to lower level but all
and in front of the gates of marine we
have the sons of the harpy just
mercilessly killing in innocence for no
reason whatsoever they look so menacing
I think especially in this episode
really hit home how menacing that must
yes if you type in sons of the harpy
into Google like the first suggestion is
mask so people are trying to buy that
masking it up to no good which is
worrying don't be causing problems on
the streets wearing that mask be the new
yeah it's like the v new v for vendetta
mask so then they are killing in a sense
but never fear the color saw is here I
come riding around the corner led by
your boy Dean heiresses toy boy Dario
Dario and he gets to swing in and then
cuts to back to Denarius who's on a
dragon mmm just flying around casually
and then from the side you see like an
explosion of fire more dragons again
like how do they what first of all
they've been trapped in the bloody
pyramid but like a whole season and a
half now why the choosing now to break
out yeah it's that perfectly timed also
they haven't been flying for like years
so their wings aren't really gonna be
strong enough are they not really and
they've kind of been in the dark as well
so they should come out and be like
what's going on out here what is
happening right and yeah and then they
like immediately synergize with each
other and I like team dragons we know
how to do this and the dragon has three
heads tomorrow yeah fine I'm going to
buy that that's okay with me I'll allow
it so then they start flying around and
sitting boats on fire it's lit the
dragons are out there they're causing
problems
regards
come back to the my masters and grey
worms like you guys screwed up man and
there and then he questions kind of the
their their soldiers loyalty it's like
do you really want to fight for these
guys when they're not ready fine for you
and the soldiers think you know what
this guy's got the right idea and they
drop their weapons and they're off and
then that's again I mean like a little
bit stupid on them because they could
have just run away and taking their
weapons because they are still gonna run
a war zone you didn't see it but they
literally ran off into dragon fire yeah
like just off-screen a dragon was like
you guys no way pick him up in you yep
p.m. and then from there they say you
know Denarius requires one of you to die
because you screwed up and they
immediately throw the lowborn master
under the bus which is pretty brutal but
grey worm in a slick move like a samurai
pulls out his knife and takes out the to
snitches and leaves the last one and
says you go home and tell everyone not
to try this again just remember what
happened when Denarius and her dragons
showed up but that's not everything that
happened in marine we later have a
meeting between Theon Yara and Daenerys
how did they get there so quickly it
just seemed like they were one minute
they were in volantis enjoying the
fruits of the ladies on offer and then
the next that you sort of in in marine
we've explained this before jetpacks
yeah but also I mean if the Masters
ships are kind of taking up all of the
dock space yeah I kind of snuck you in
between let hey guys but like they have
a discussion and it's basically them
trying to forge an alliance and you get
this amazing kind of back and forth
where Yara and Daenerys basically
realized that they're very similar and
then they give each other the eyes like
wood and then she looks back and is like
wood I mean Yura outright yeah yeah
she's like yeah so the thing is like
they say Oh has the iron Isles ever had
a queen and and then she replies as much
as Westeros has ever had like
yeah like it yes we're gonna say hell
over together I'm friends and then it's
like oh yeah your dad's a bit of a [ __ ]
ruler and she replies so was yours and
then they're like let's do this so then
they come to an agreement Theon's like
now I don't really want to be king just
leave it to her and then they shake
hands and Elijah shake elbows year and I
really like that handshake in Game of
Thrones i'm going to start shaking more
elbows in my daily life
starting with you I think is also worth
mentioning that Theon shows that he has
no interest in being a king and his kind
of weave get we've got the new Theon
where he acknowledges what he's done in
the past he says you know I've done
things a lot worse than you know what
was suggested there and he's willing to
kind of let his sister take take charge
on becoming the leader of the islands
but not only that I mean you've got
Tyrion saying oh the last time I saw you
you were you know saying all these dwarf
jokes and just basically getting on your
high horse what happened to you kind of
thing so kind of it acts like tyrion
doesn't really know the extent of
Theon's punishment yeah or has changed
like was he on replace that was a long
time ago so he's not not everyone's
aware that he's changed and he he
doesn't seem to be reflecting on what
happened to him as well because she's
dinner mrs. like what happened to you
and he doesn't really say look what
tortured I got my balls cut off just
like no worry about it and now he's had
a drink yes fine he had a nice big drink
and that sorted him out okay so the big
takeaway for this is Daenerys is ready
to get stuck into the fray she's gonna
get off that rock climbing finally yeah
ah um also I think it's interesting that
like she's got the master ships now
she's got part of the iron iron fleet
but it's like that why they leading up
to this confrontation with your own
right because her ultimate goal is to
get the whole of the Seven Kingdoms so
giving the Iron Islands back to the back
to the Greyjoy's I guess I can kind of
see but it's interesting that she's like
oh yeah they can ask for their
independence that seems kind of out of
character because she wants to control
the world so giving like divvying away
her kingdom before she's even got it
seems a bit yeah I mean she's got a like
her take the battle step-by-step right
and the Greyjoy's and getting the Iron
Islands on her team may be a way to do
that and she seems to be trying to
change what they are as well because she
said like you can you can carry on and
you know have your Iron Islands back as
long as you stop raping pillaging and
you know murdering anyone want only and
they like that's our way this is that
well you either change or you you know
don't get what you want
she's kind of almost molding a new army
to go back to and using them may be used
what she has there to slowly take over
different houses different areas to
ultimately leave that final battle in
King's Landing yeah but is she gonna be
the one to lead that army or is Jon Snow
I don't mean like the ultimate fighter
all right well it's likely to be a team
up right yeah Jon Snow realizes that he
doesn't actually care and he just wants
to kind of put an end to all this maybe
get some revenge on someone later on
down the line and who knows to get
married and have beautiful baby it's not
gonna happen oh the Dragons won't allow
it but another thing that was really
teased in this bit was the the wildfire
so we know that from brands vision that
was definitely wild fire under there
we've heard it said in previous episodes
superion they seeded the wild fiber now
it's like Tyrians like yep is there and
it's everywhere yeah do we think Cersei
is gonna just burn them all so in the
last episode we had Cersei talking to
the maester about some sort of was rumor
right yeah rumor and I originally
thought it was about like some illicit
thing that the you know the high spiral
may have done I thought it to be honest
I thought it'd be about um catlin yeah
perhaps yeah that she's you know she's
alive reliable something like that but
it's likely based on this that you know
she's discovered a new cachet of
wildfire conveniently placed underneath
the exact place where she's going to be
having her trial soon yeah and obviously
because trial by combat has now been
ruled out and she can't get her zombie
night to take care of everyone she's
gonna have to take more extreme measures
which is interesting because there's
going to be a lot of fallout if that is
the case yeah because you think she
could wipe out the whole of the faith
but she could also wipe out her son
Madhuri and Loras you wipe out herself I
think she's reached a point where her
son's kind of a little like less
important to her now after the obvious
betrayal that she's been going through
his hands I think she might be more
willing to be like let's set this little
brown fire so I can get the hell out of
here this episode though is the battle
of the bastard so let's talk a little
bit about like the lead-up into it
because it was a lot of drams yeah there
was a lot of drama a lot of sass
as well so on the outskirts of
Winterfell we have a standoff between
Sansa and John vs Ramsay we also have a
backing lie group which is an incredibly
sour face Lyanna Mormont feel like that
girl I mean she's only about 10 or 12
she's just grown up on a diet of your
lemons we were so salt yeah lemons and
soul back in it like sour skittles just
I'm oh yeah she's she looks like she's
ready for murder like when she grows up
she's gonna own the entire Atari of
Westeros here we also have Davos and
tormund there mm-hmm and Ramses
basically saying kneel before zod and
all be forgiven snooty booty yeah yeah
no and they're like no we don't want to
do that and he's being an absolute [ __ ]
bag the entire time he's like in the
morning then blasted and now he'd that
he's no longer a bus that he can rub it
in on all the other bastards so they're
they're like and he's reminding him
about how small the armies are
comparatively but John does get his own
little jab in he plays a bit of mind
games he's like 1v1 me scrub and and
Ramses like no that's not wise so then
John comes out with like how your main
gonna feel knowing you know will they
really fight for you knowing that you
wouldn't step up when you were
challenged so I think it's quite nice
that in the in the marine section they
also had that moment of you know your
rule is not gonna fight for you it's
almost as if it's the song of ice and
fire and they were the two key like
parts of it here we go with the babies
again that's gonna so then after that
Ramsey reminds him that he has Rick on
and we get this amazing line from Sansa
yeah if you want to say you're going to
die tomorrow Lord Bolton sleep well
so bastard bowl is on and the team gets
a planning there's a bit of comic relief
here where Tolman's like pincer attack
Oh bless ya and the other one which is
like a double envelopment which one even
I was like what were you doing and then
eventually John's like from the sides
and torn goes gotcha I understand so
then when they leave Sansa gets up and
she's she reminds John that out of all
of them she has the best insight into
Ramsey feel like she's complaining that
he didn't ask her advice what did she
just give it shows there it's not like
he had a hand or a mouth yeah just
volunteer your sage like wisdom if
you've got it so she says I know what
he's like and essentially is like he's
if you think that you're getting the
upper hand you know he's actually in
playing he's you ain't he's laying the
trap and allowing you to fall into it
and then she's also shows that she's
prepared for recon to die which is kind
of at issue is indicative of the change
in Sansa right she's gone from being
damsel in distress to the basically
being like stressed ratted can't say the
word strategist strategist she's
basically gone from Danzo in distress to
being a strategist so she's like yeah
chances are you know recons you know the
heir to Winterfell and a challenge to
Ramsey his chances aren't good so she's
almost like come to terms with the idea
that her younger brother's gonna die
while John still hasn't yeah I feel like
she spent a lot of time with
Littlefinger though right she's more
calculating she's more aware of the
risks and like the costs if they want to
get Winterfell back then yeah Ramsey was
always gonna love it yeah you definitely
on the way out she turned and she's like
listen if Ramsey wins I'm not going back
there alive do you understand me I won't
ever let him touch you again I'll
protect you I promise no one can protect
me no one can protect anyone so wrapping
things up here outside we get some bands
between Davos and tallman they talk
about pledging themselves to kings and
then is this how it doesn't really pass
yeah it doesn't work really well and
there's discussion about how they deal
with like pre-battle stress tormund
likes a bit of nasty goats milk which is
a really weird way to deal with it while
Davis is like I'm gonna walk I'm gonna
think get the pen and I'm gonna keep
going until no one can hear me pooping
and then we get an amazing torment line
probably the best in the season so far
happy shitty out on his walk things take
a turn for the worst that was finds a
pyre and amongst it he finds a toy a
little stag that he made for someone
special you know when he was picking up
and you couldn't really see what it was
I thought it was her hands Oh like the
grayscale meant it didn't melt no that
would have been even more devastating
than it was half a face yeah so like
just a phantom of the opera style mask
layer and then he wears it as a mask and
becomes like an Avenger I could be the
Phantom about yeah so so he finds a toy
and it is obviously the toy that he made
for Shireen realizes what's happened
here daddy sacrificed Dora and
Melisandre had had a hand in burning the
young lady I love how this one out on
Father's Day as well yeah top number one
dad Stannis worst guy so meanwhile
inside John and Melisandre meeting and
he's like listen if I die this time
don't bring me back i'm done with this
stuff and medicine was like it depends
on what Lord of Light says yeah I'm just
doing what he tells me anyway says he's
like like the guy man I love the way
that he was like how do you know what
you want you and she's like oh I just
didn't you know try and interpret yeah I
symbol read the signs just anything like
sometimes it doesn't yep and that's
that's the end of it so the selp is
ready there that's the intro to the
the bastards I thought the the Davos
realization was incredibly well done
yeah like it was the thread was it
sunrise and sunset yeah in the
background and just like that incredible
shot where he's standing back and I
thought that it meant that when he went
into battle he would be just didn't care
yeah but it was kind of good to see him
be more tactical and still be of use I
think he wanted to survive so that my
lasandra could get her Commandments yeah
I was convinced that this would be the
end of Devil's like this would be his
moment we'd go out in a blaze of anger
and glory in fury but he seems to have
stayed composed which means he clearly
has a plan he's got something cooking
maybe it's time for him to break his
allegiances with the Lord of Light and
his priestesses mmm okay the battle
itself now the go directed this episode
Miguel support sick nailed it I hope
look I right but he directed hard home
from last season so we kind of know that
he can do the big battle sequences but
to be honest I was blown away by this
one same because I mean we'll talk about
the choreography in a minute but just
the way that it managed to portray just
how awful the battle like war like that
really is like none of it was like
glorified it was all just grow some
people lying on the ground and horses
collapsing and arrows and swords and oh
that was the worst bit like I was ok
with the the people getting hit by
swords when two horses slam into each
other that was the one that was like oh
god sake stop this it was also amazing
cuz it like held you like the tension
was right throughout so we can talk
about some real key moments in it
because i don't think i've ever seen
about a sequence quite i think that
might be my favorite but what i loved
about is like in films like lord of
rings is very like top down it's also
it's very top down but it's also very
zippy so you know like that camera angle
will just keep moving all around
actually reminded me a lot of Mad Max in
a way because you know I get it in
typically like in things like Lord of
the Rings the camera like zips around it
moves all over you can't really follow
the action but in Mad Max it's like
center frame and you can always see
what's happening what's going on and
that was incredible so when you're
following John as he's out in the
battlefield
you know the armies are crushing in
around him you can follow him and you
can see the horses yeah colliding you
can see men fighting and the way that
the archery you know the arrows are ours
commander I'm you get to see did you see
like a lot of these movies you see like
the hero running in and just
effortlessly swinging from one person
over but in this one we got to see a lot
of near-misses where John could have
almost got like taken out yeah but like
saved by fortune with someone else
stumbled into the way it's just a really
like it reminded me a lot of like video
the way video games would approach about
oh wait it's like right son of Rome like
foreign almost like getting right into
the nitty-gritty of him following the
character stumbling around and getting
bloody yeah but it really kept you even
from the very beginning so when you got
Ramsey dragging I mean we already knew
it was Rick on right when he was
dragging him and he there's this
lingering shot it was very deliberate
the shot of Ramses flying so we think
the richens gonna get flayed or
something out on the battlefield but no
it's something kind of even worse he
goes full apocalypto yep um and I mean I
guess Rick on never learned about zigzag
no he didn't so like dive just I just
random moments just do it I mean
although props to Ramsey because I
imagine a shoot a moving targets very
difficult to shoot I mean he missed like
three times you did what you did hit
them yeah eventually at the worst
possible moment like I kind of feel bad
for the actor who plays Rick on cuz he
got brought back with this season I
don't think he had a single line yeah um
but no I thought that was great in the
way that you know John immediately
understand what's happening gets on his
horse and comes in but then what he does
is he falls for the bait and he
completely Biff's it it's the one thing
that Sansa warned him against was
richens probably gonna die we have to be
alright with that because that's
Ramsay's trap that's his ace in the hole
so what does John do ride straight into
the enemy by himself like a idiot but I
mean that that bid where John's in the
thick of it and the the two armies crash
around it yeah we're seriously seriously
incredible but let's talk a little about
the Army's involved because there was a
long past lat a long-standing fan theory
that maybe the Karstarks or the umbers
would remain loyal to the Starks
actually turn on Ramsey money
they didn't they did there was a moment
where we speculated maybe they were
doing a really wide turn like going all
the way around the battlefield to come
back around but that very quickly kind
of was dashed unfortunately but also I
thought the bit where they were seeding
you know like oh they don't want to
fight for the Bolton's they have to that
might be you know that they would turn
yeah I don't want to fight for the bones
and the pacing of it was in a way that
like they came out and they were slowly
surrounding everyone there was a lot of
pauses where every time it happened I
was like this is the moment we're gonna
turn this is the moment where they gonna
turn but I was like no just setting up
the worst death for everyone in there I
mean if it was bad enough as well the
Ramsey was essentially firing into his
own men yeah he was getting the the
archers in the Longboat five straight
into them because just basically a whole
pool of death yeah so he probably killed
more of his own men and John's army did
conversely Davis was like let's not do
this they didn't fire the arrows because
that was be killing their own men I mean
he had more opportunity to do it because
they've got less man yeah and runs you
can afford to just like be disposing of
his army but then then we got as you
said to the bit where it just got so
brutal today the Bolton armies in this
big U shape and there's this pile of
bodies and it's the bit where you know
all the wildlings are packed in and
they've got the the Pikes closing in on
them but also you have the other people
scrambling over the bodies was still
alive yeah you know they get the guys
are holding their innards in and then
you've got the umbers i believe it's
coming over and just stop them getting
out that way you know my god and john's
like underneath a pile of bodies just
desperately trying to go that was
genuinely turn yeah me I thought that
was incredibly well done because the
cluster folios oh my god like I'm a
small person so I don't really like gigs
because I feel like that yeah I've never
been I'm pretty much the same as a big
person but I'm like oh god it just made
me feel really uncomfortable and i
genuinely felt this is it this is yeah
especially with that conversation with
malice and ray where she's like he might
have brought you back just to die yeah
so you did genuinely feel like hmm he
probably wasn't safe but then you should
boy oh my goodness with his Gandalf the
Grey no Gandalf the White moment yeah
the white come on now
get this Lord of the Rings reference
proper okay he yeah John dawn he looked
at the east yep and there they were the
Knights of the Vale so we we called that
yeah we saw that coming but I mean I
first of all let's just take a moment to
appreciate little fingers shit-eating
great yeah I know the work the best
thing about it was the placement was
perfect because the camera was focused
on Sansa but if you look to the left a
bit you just see him he's like I'm the
real hero here although what what kind
of did annoy me is that he was in the
opening credits yes I kind of wish that
they hadn't done that I mean it wasn't
obvious didn't happen but if ifs answer
as well Santa had a go at John Wright
being like oh you never let me help you
never let me help but cuz you didn't
tell any where she was doing I mean it's
a pretty big like strategic bit of
information that John should probably
have known going in like what you've got
how many more men are gonna appear how
many more well trained and rested men
who are all on horses seem totally save
our we delay this for a couple of hours
while they you know get their act
together basically it's the Battle of
Helm's Deep so after the Knights of the
Vale arrived Ramsey only then does he
really think that all's lost he sort of
seems ambivalent about the whole thing
it was in that moment that Ramsay Bolton
realized that he screwed up for once in
their lives yeah and he you know
retreats back to Winterfell and he
thinks oh it's fine yeah we'll just
starve them out we've got no army
they've got no army apart from the new
army that just joined them and that was
a weird thing from say as well as I do
mommy's apart from you know of all those
all those dudes that you showed up and
also they have a Hulk say basically
which appears and just start stomping
around and pushing yes so John who's a
John torment and 11 chase after
Winterfell and one one does what one one
does best and that is breakdown yeah big
oak wooden doors um but sadly oh man
this was devastating I really didn't
like this he became a giant pin cushion
I'm so bad and then you know just after
he breaks through with John and John
look Sam you know what this we did it
and when one just gets one in the eye
Ramses final final and so
yeah now we can hit a target yeah now we
can do it so John Ramsey finally then
have their one-on-one neither of them
actually seem to use swords though which
they're dumb yeah so Ramsey's using a
bow and arrow in an enclosed space and
John throws down his sword completely
and just picks up a shield but what is
good about the shield is that it's a
Mormon shield yes oh leanna moment you
know we took the mick we were like oh 62
men that's nothing well the strength of
those sixty two men were in that shield
and they saved John's life yeah I mean a
sword probably would have helped but
like wherever in it that kind of annoyed
me because I was like what you doing
yeah like I guess it is like him this
moment of pure rage way he's like Swan
hit him with my hands until he is pulp
say like threw it away and I was like
I'm grabbing the shield getting up close
and going in do some work well I did
like is when he was you know pulping
Ramsey's face yeah he stopped and looked
at Sansa so I thought Sansa would give
him you know the nod as if to say kill
him but he knew that like it was hers
yeah yeah Ramsey's life was hers and she
could do with it as she wished yep and
it was it was very cathartic to see Jon
Snow pummeling that guy there's
something about his smug little face
that I've wanted to see get punched for
so long still arrogant like to the very
very end he smiled at the last moment as
well yeah or maybe that's just cuz all
the bones in his face it broken oh yeah
yeah so then Ramsay is tied up in the
kennels and well I mean we already
recognized it as a candidate but the
doors are already open yeah and it's
another one of those incredibly well
trained animal moments where they don't
attack him until Sansa's managed to say
her incredibly badass line but you know
that was obviously a well-deserved
ending for Ramsey I thought I thoughts
character was brilliant I really liked
him he's really one-dimensional he's
very I mean he's probably the most hated
character in that even wasn't Joffrey Oh
of the sea I think even more than
Joffrey cuz Joffrey was a little [ __ ]
but this guy was like scheming in ways
and like torturing everyone we loved and
oh my god it's his face as well
Joffrey's like had one of those like
faces that language just want to hit him
but this guy he's got like oh god he's
so smug I hit him but no I'm glad that
it was son so who was kind of there as
the is the dog's jaws yeah the jaws are
the dog literally ate his jaw which was
amazing I mean if you don't feed your
bloodthirsty hounds for seven days then
that's gonna end badly for someone and
it ended badly for him I have a question
where was ghost there are this entire
thing right that that wolf I mean
direwolves entirely there just in this
series they've just gotten built a
reputation for me incredibly flaky maybe
she's doing I'll you the CGI budget yeah
maybe the ghosts realized what's
happened to rest the direwolf son was
like I need to get the hell out of here
these guys are no good unless maybe he
stayed with Melisandre mmm did like him
I'll protect you I doubt it I think
needs to run for it he's like I'm out of
here but what was interesting to know in
that final conversation between santa
and Ramsey now you see I thought this
was a clunky bit of dialogue until I
kind of watched it again hmm our time
together is about to come that's all you
can't kill me I'm part of you so I
thought it was like a clunky bit of
dialogue at first cuz he says I'm part
of you so he can either interpret that
in in two ways either she's pregnant
which is what i think is Oh gross but
how would he know that I don't know no
he just knows he says he knows he has a
way of like he's like the Joker even
after he's done with Batman he's been
captured he can say this one thing and
know that it's just gonna be in his head
forever yeah so the Ramseys like I'm
part you know I'm part of you know
that's also a really gross voice yes
awful um all the fact that you know
after all the torture and everything
he's he's in her head now yeah does that
mean I mean we know the science is
getting more calculated and you know not
uncaring but she's taking bigger risks
like about Rick on she kind of knew that
that had to happen is that what he means
yeah he has kind of changed her
personality somewhat
he's one of the people and a little
fingers also contribute to that I
Joffrey for example but like he he might
have put in the part way it's become a
bit malicious yes small enough and maybe
that's something that's explored going
forward like a willingness to just throw
Rick on away is a small example of that
but maybe that's something that over
time will grow and would be like oh my
god she's a Bolton oh maybe she'll just
be a mrs. little finger with a hint of
all time now as always for death of the
world don't worry tricky time because
there are about 3,000 I like the
different flavors of death so like
you've got some generic random death
battle dare you got some sad death and
then you got some you deserve that death
so let's pick a few of our favorites I
think wooden ones death was incredible
yeah I mean not for you know knocks I
was happy to see it happening I thought
it was a befitting tribute and also
quite a nice parallel to holders death
soho doll you don't have to had to hold
the door
where's my 11 broke through the door
it's important to forget it's important
to remember sorry how important 11 was
like he was he helped sway the welding
and the free folk vote right Yes No
people like that big guys right snow and
he kind of got them behind and he sees
been around for so long and had massive
impact I wish that he was a little more
he had had more of like an impact in
within bowels because like you just see
him slowly running towards bottles but
he was amazing for like breaking through
fortifications that kind of stuff and he
didn't deserve to go the way he did he I
wanted John and him to have that final
moment where they touch hands and be
like we did it buddy flipping Ramsey
with his arrow there were a couple of
people who got their comeuppance in this
episode not only Ramsey but i think the
small john it's a small Joe number the
one who gave wreck on to Ramsey finally
you know it wasn't a confrontation
between him and John as I kind of hoped
it would be but damn woman tolman got in
there so I mean there was a really
heated fight between them and you know
small Jones's head-butting yeah torment
and it was gross and I thought that
would be the end of torment around us
but then you know wildling tactic never
turn your back on a what don't give a
waddling a second don't keep boiling a
bit of a neck yep they will taste that
Nick so you went straight in rip sit
down and stabs him and I thought that
was a befitting savage shall we say my
personal death of the week Ramsey just
for the sheer brutality of it I miss him
already yeah and it's a two-part death
so the first part is where John gets him
and delivers i think it was 21 punches
that was Kelly so I was counting our way
to savor every single one command
everyone to memory so that was beautiful
because it's you know real hand-to-hand
stuff and then the next one is irony
yeah finally he got he got his own taste
of his own medicine he's all got a taste
of his yeah something like that and I'll
the thing that made his sweet for me was
he was convinced that the dogs wouldn't
betray him he was like yeah he was like
sit and the dog was like I'm gonna your
face gonna lick your face yet for a
moment like i showed the front of dog a
dog was looking quite cute like yes
ramsey are you doing and then then he
realized I'm hungry I'm gonna eat this
dude and like the way that the dog's
mouth just went around ramsis jaw and
then there was a crunch I was beautiful
okay time now for another spoiler
warning if you don't want to see
anything from next week's episode which
is the season finale then turn away now
because we're going to be dissecting the
little tease that we had at the end of
episode 9 okay so we know that episode
10 is Circe's trial so trial by combat
Clegane ball has been ruled out but we
hear the high Sparrow say are you
prepared to stand trial and profess your
guilt or innocence before the seven so
they're in the scepter bail or and there
is wildfire up in there there is we also
get a look at loris mm-hmm he's gonna
his pretty curls yeah he's looking
pretty bead yeah he also looks like he's
gonna crack yeah he looks like he's
ready to flip on anyone and everyone
mm-hmm so so this next scene is pretty
interesting so next episode is called
the winds of winter and this is a white
Raven so this is what the maesters send
to signal the season has changed why do
they need to do that just like look
outside cuz they're like you know really
important weathermen and they need to
tell everyone but so the season is
officially changing winter is coming
well technically winters here yeah um
but then we have Sansa and John and they
don't seem to be getting on hmm are they
going on or what I saw was like them
fortifying their new relationship
it seemed to be John doing that this
answer seemed to be very hesitant I mean
the thing is like little fingers back in
the action now and there's a scene later
on where they're talking I think this
might be a situation where they're
creating a new allegiance to kind of get
to scheme in together unless it seems
like sansas making an allegiance with
both of them and they're not really all
three and talking yeah maybe would be
quite interesting um but then we get
quite quite an unusual scene jamie is in
the twins with the phrase so we thought
that after he'd secured Riverrun he
would just hop skip and jump right back
to King's Landing to me with his beloved
Cersei but no he's gone to see Walder
Frey for some reason for some reason and
the Walder Frey says the phrase and the
Lannisters send their regards oh no one
cuts deep which doesn't sound that good
and also I'm interested to see if
there's any fallout from Ed Muir you
know being manipulated by Jamie into
getting Riverrun back maybe maybe Jamie
promised that he would get revenge on
the phrase then as you mentioned we got
Sampson little finger love is in the air
is it it's like force love yeah I mean
admittedly one of them's in love yeah
the other ones like I just saved your
ass you bad the other ones like I'm not
my mum leave me alone and then we
finally get this confrontation that I've
been wanting for a long time and that's
Davros in malice Andre hmm and oh it
looks it looks heated yeah Davos is
looking very very upset I mean
rightfully so but also like tell him
what you did tell him yeah um I mean a
Melisandre is she could be let you I did
it she's done it before I she's like
yeah I popped out a demon she looks very
guilty about it though which is
something that she's not we're not used
to seeing mm-hmm she I mean her her
faith has been somewhat shaken recently
but then she brought okay back from the
dead but she doesn't seem to be
convinced that she managed it herself
like her power is her faith in her own
power seems to be waning which could
translate into a waning of faith in the
Lord of Light hmm and then we have a
shot of bran this guy again if I don't
get the damn Tower of joy reveal okay
this is ridiculous you've taken Clegane
ball
away from me gave me the touch I just
need to know I need to know what's in
there I mean we already kind of know
it's it yeah we know what's in there do
we though a lot of red herring yeah
these things are changing from the books
um and then we've got um are you afraid
you're in the great game now but blah so
hopefully this means that De Niro so get
off her ass and actually get on a boat
um I really really hope also this kind
of weird scene where a tire and Daario
naharis and I'm kind of wondering yeah
is that a goodbye is does he refuse to
leave second songs I would be really
amazing if the actual scene is that
happening and then captain friend zone
returns at that moment I was like I'm
back baby I fixed it don't do this to me
I can't bear if he's bout he probably
will return to be honest yeah and then
we have a guy walking so I have zoomed
and enhanced this I've looked it up on
google images that's acceptable or this
door hmm who is leaving you seem to
think it's well no because I thought it
was me sick i burn right because here
you can see a chain on here but we were
sad we compared the haircuts yeah my
bands got a little bit of a flicking
yeah curls at the bottom so this could
be land cell which lancel also has
changed and yep so that's who I'm being
on I wonder what his role will be if he
you know he's seen firsthand the power
of the mountain could he really betray
sir see again I don't know trusting um
but what I want to do tomorrow I want to
make some predictions okay on what the
last shot of the seasons gonna be
alright so there's a few we can pick
from so King's Landing burning yes he
goes full heiress yeah I think there's a
good chance of that happening next
episode I also think the wall could come
down oh no sir that's a big one so if we
know the brand is basically broken the
magic that kept the night yeah baby cuz
you got touched God's sake man if he
goes south of the wall I think that's
the best one I think I think that's the
most likely one for me because we've
gotten quite thick into the politics
between different houses right now
and it's easy to lose sight of the
bigger picture and I think they're going
to take the opportunity to remind people
actually this is all inconsequential
because there's this horde of frost
zombies on their way yeah another
another thing maybe it could be Lady
Stoneheart no I mean they keep saying
you know oh we've never had any
conversations about Lady Stoneheart
Stephanie not happening definitely not
happening well they said that about Jon
Snow's death okay yeah they said that he
was like oh yeah he's dead a definite
not coming back look where we are now
morning to show up yeah um that's a good
one that would be a good one like you
know an eyes-open final frame kind of
things like blood shiz the final the
final thing that I think could be the
last scene want it to be I want to be
the last scene is the Tower of joy but
knowing game of thrones and knowing our
luck they'll probably open the door hmm
and that'll cut their yep so that was
episode nine tomorrow how do you think
it went I really liked it I liked it a
lot a lot of people that i dislike goft
mm-hmm I've got to see an awesome battle
sequence mm-hmm and he's setting up for
an incredible season finale I'm really
excited because I've been I've been
worried about this season a little bit
some of the some of the story arcs
haven't necessarily gone where I thought
they would but i'm so glad that episode
9 is kind of just put everyone back on
the right path i think and also that
battle sequence is not something i'm
gonna be forgetting anytime soon I
really really enjoyed it and it's the
same director for the next episode as
well so here's hoping in season 7 they
gave him a bunch more episodes to do
it's gonna be an incredible sand snakes
episode stop this shout out to sand
snakes you still haven't been in since
episode one I think they've just quietly
pushed him into the sea poochie out back
to their home planet but please make
sure to join us next Monday as we'll be
talking about this season finale I'm so
excited although I have to wait a whole
week no which I'm quite disappointed
about but in the meantime you can find
me in tomorrow and Twitter time I'm at
two more hay and i'm at Lucy James games
if you're listening to the audio version
of this glorious show then head over to
iTunes such a game spot of Thrones and
we will see you next week